so hey ed now for our hipster shop app
we've got some basic services set up but
my site is getting so popular I need to
do more SEO can help with that too there
are all kinds of advanced traffic
management features you can do to
control your content great so does that
mean that you're gonna show me how it
works before my site becomes too
mainstream sure thing let's jump right
into it
so right away we're at hipster shop
version one we can scroll through the
web page we can click on products and we
can figure out if we want to add them to
our cart or not but right away let's
let's take a step back here let's go
back to our main page and let's let's
figure out how we want to do routing to
our front ends so first here we'll run a
command to see the different front ends
that we're running and you see right
here we're running three different
versions of our front-end so what we'll
do now is we'll take a look at the
virtual services that are running and
we'll take a look to see what the front
end virtual service is actually doing
and how its routing traffic currently so
when we run this command
we'll see here that all the traffic is
being routed to some subset of our pods
known as version one now what what does
v1 mean so here what we'll do is we'll
take a look at the destination rules and
in particular we'll take a look at the
front end destination rule to see what
v1 means when we take a look at this we
see that b1 relates the version one of
our application b2 to version 2 and B 3
to version 3 a nice simple way of kind
of keeping all this organized so right
here we have a user that's already on
the web page so let's take a look at
what we would do to route this users
traffic to version 2 of the web page so
this user has a shop session cookie so
we'll apply that into our virtual
service and we'll apply this yamo file
and we'll go and we'll take a look at a
web page will reload the page and we
notice now that this user is currently
being routed the version 2 of the web
page so we'll take this again link we'll
go into an incognito window and we'll
see what other users are seeing and you
see right away that they're being routed
to version 1 of the web page so now
that's great now but what if we want to
do some you know canary deployments or
some 80/20 or traffic splitting between
our different versions so the next thing
we'll do is we'll take a look at a yamo
file which shows us what it would look
like to split traffic 75% to version 1
and 25% to version 3 for all users who
are
currently not on the page so right here
it's just as simple as adding a weight
to the ml file so we'll go ahead and
apply this and then we'll go back and
check on our webpage so for the user
that's currently has a session ID
we'll keep refreshing the page and if
you notice here it's still being routed
to version to the website so now let's
open another incognito window and let's
see what's going on for what all the
other user sees so you see right away
that they're at hipster shop version one
if we reload the page a couple of times
we should see about one in every four
refresh get routed to version 3 of the
web page now this gives you a very
simple way to route traffic and do some
splitting between your services and
simple enough that was traffic
management this you and it was as easy
as that to do weighted traffic
distribution to different versions of
our app yeah behind the scenes
is he--oh soon all the routing and work
making it super easy for DevOps don't
forget to Like comment and subscribe for
our next episode on Sto and if you'd
like to get in contact with us click on
the link in the description
[Music]